welcome to your mom's house
do you want sure
so this is a jacket I got after I
delivered my baby out I tipped the
scales at 200 pounds I say that so I was
super fat and I went to H&M I got this
jacket and I had it tailored so that it
kind of concealed my disgusting fatness
it's got like a little single button to
be clear I didn't say I don't like it
right all I said was you look like mrs.
Stein my art teacher okay okay that's
great okay and you can put you know
markers and brushes and stuff in there
and it just has that nice bullet really
yeah what you should like it there's
first of all you said thank you for
protecting me you are gonna separating
it I'm not gonna smell especially we're
gonna get into painting it's like a
perfect thing to wear you think you know
that you're saying like are just really
big like a big jacket and then you can
put paint in their pockets you know you
can